welcome
to the week in 60 minutes from spectator
tv
the show that makes headlines around the
world
our interview with david nabarro of the
world health organization last week was
raised in the house of commons
reported in newspapers from new york to
new zealand
and even tweeted by donald trump if you
missed it
you can catch up on our youtube channel
tonight i'll be speaking to posters
pundits and a politician
about the proliferation of lockdown
rules
in the uk which over half of the
population
now find themselves in were to increased
restrictions
france where president macron has taken
a stance against
islamic extremism and we will finish
with brexit
yes it's still with us what's the latest
from brussels
as ever we'll take questions from the
audience in the last 10 minutes or so
you can email them
at spectator tv at spectator dot co
dot uk that's spectator tv at spectator
dot co
dot uk throughout the show you can
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel for free
if you're already watching on youtube
just tap the subscribe button in the
bottom right hand corner of your screen
you'll then receive a notification
whenever a new episode
is aired a special thanks to charles
stanley for supporting
this episode charles stanley is one of
the uk's leading wealth management firms
and one of the oldest firms on the
london stock exchange
so to our first topic local lockdowns
it's been another febrile week in
british politics
vast ways of the country are in various
shades of lockdown
some regions are fighting to keep their
medium-risk status
how's the fighting to get into tier
three that's the highest level
excuse me to access the economic support
that comes with it from central
government
london faces stricter rules comes
saturday thanks to mir sadiq khan
who wants neither the economic packages
that come with tier three
nor apparently the civil liberties of
tier one
boris johnson is no longer following the
signs
quite labour leader kia starmer wants
another national lockdown in the form of
a so-called circuit breaker
and most folk are just confused by the
bewildering array of restrictions
that now face them depending on where
they live let's go straight to
our political ledger james forsythe
james it would seem to me that the
government is
now being pummeled on all sides
yeah andrew i think you're right i i say
in the magazine this week that boris
johnson's gone from being a politician
defined by his commitment to having his
cake and eating it
to being one who's damned if he does and
damned if he doesn't
uh take kierstram adopting the sage
proposal of
a national circuit breaker uh if boris
johnson
isn't is currently not intending to go
down that route if the excess deaths
numbers this winter are high
kirsten will say well look if you'd
follow the scientific advice they would
be lower
but at the same time boris johnson has
to deal with the economic and societal
damage
of further lockdowns and i think this is
what is it is an almost impossible path
to chart his way through and i think
what's very telling
is uh how you know in france you've got
emmanuel macron following a very similar
strategy to boris johnson you know of
local lockdowns
designed to avoid the catastrophe of a
second national lockdown
and i think at the beginning of this
week when kier starmer
went through it on the stage proposals
and said look you should be going for
the circuit breaker
uh i think there was a lot of concern in
downing street i think they think that
if they
the the the the gap between boris and
his own mps which was
growing dangerously large because on the
clover restrictions
has been shortened by this because they
are happier
arguing against uh the national circuit
breaker which is effectively a soft
lockdown
and you know that borisov is an argument
a prime minister's question so you know
why would you shut pubs in cornwall
when there's almost no covet down there
that is something that the tory benches
can get behind
so last week on the show we talked to
the
irish times as pat lee about how
politicians there they
they've separated from the scientists
the their equivalent of sage gave the
government the irish government advice
about a strong lockdown the irish
government said no
what we didn't know at the time was that
that was exactly what was happening in
britain
uh james but it was happening in
september i think in the third week of
september
we just didn't know about it the
argument that has played out
in this country is exactly the same as
the argument played out in ireland
except in ireland it played out in
public and here it played out behind
closed doors and i think what you see is
scientists saying
you know go to circuit breaker soft
lockdown whatever you want to call it
and the politician's saying
we can't do that because of the economic
and social damage that will cause and i
think one of the things that is
complicated the situation is in both
the irish cases and the british cases i
get the strong
impression but the scientists knew that
they are effectively involved in a
negotiation
and so they're pitching but but for a
maximalist position
to try because they know that the
politicians are unlikely to do precisely
what they say
i think one thing boris johnson needs to
do though is be much clearer
about why he's not following the science
i thought you know in ireland you had
the deputy prime minister leo vargas be
very explicit
about why the coalition government there
was not doing what the scientists were
saying
you know pointing out that he'd ask the
scientists they could guarantee that
this circuit breaker would only be
needed for four weeks
and they couldn't uh and also saying
look it's fine for these scientists to
recommend more and more lockdowns you
know they're not at risk of losing their
jobs they're not going to have to lay
people off i think boris johnson needs a
moment like that
where he is explicit about why he's not
following the scientists you know he was
discussed on sunday at a long discussion
of emmanuel macron about clovid
macron was very straight with the french
people when schools went back he said
look
but scientists do not recommend this but
i am saying i am doing this because i am
the president of the republic and i
think this is
more important and i think boris johnson
needs a moment when he says to the
public look
i'm not just going to do what sage say
because i am the prime minister of
country i've got to balance
all of these factors i think he needs to
be explicit about that with the british
people
let's go to katie balls our political
correspondent katie
what's the political significance of kia
starmar
now putting clear blue water between
labor and the government on how to
handle the covert crisis
well i think there are a few aspects to
it uh we now have that clear dividing
line
um there was a point i think in recent
weeks where it was quite hard to
actually differentiate
labour's position from the governments
on coronavirus lokistan would huff and
puff at the dispatch box
and he would ultimately support a lot of
the measures and that was uh causing
some anxiety amongst his own mps they
wanted him to go for the government on
this so
on the surface i think that kierstama's
intervention has been well received in
his own party
i also think it's worth remembering his
own golden rule of opposition politics
which is
only ask for things you think are
actually going to happen
and kiss dama takes the view that
there's not much point calling on
someone to resign
if they're not going to because you will
look ineffective as though your calls
don't lead to much so
clearly there's a calculation in the
leader's office that we are heading to a
circuit breaker
as james touched on it has had this
effect of almost rallying the tory party
kirsten has somehow managed to almost
unite the tory party
lockdown skeptics very annoyed at boris
johnson be it briefly because there is a
worse alternative
but i think there's a real risk for
boris johnson which is
a lot of people in government and some
in downing street think that we are
still heading to something that
looks a lot like a circuit breaker i
think there's some talk about rebranding
a circuit breaker
so you you know you don't use that
phrase but ultimately it does look like
a brief
well hopefully brief lockdown and i
think that if he
ends up doing what uh labour has called
for if he has to use labor votes to get
there
um this brief uh i suppose a period of
empties backing him
will go much worse than actually
previous and and he's going to have a
lot of problems in his own party
so we still got to see the test of how
it plays out but
i think that on the surface this is okay
forest johnson but if he actually ends
up doing something like a circuit
breaker it's going can be very difficult
for the prime minister
because in northern ireland where
there's a circuit breaker it turns out
to be four weeks so it's not that short
is it it's people talked about two weeks
but in northern ireland it's four
which is not that different from a
lockdown as
we went into james what's the politics
of this i mean the
the government surrounded on all sides
by its critics
it's kind of got to get this right is it
not the course of action is taken
it has to be right to dumbfound its
critics otherwise it's going to have to
give into its critics
i i think as casey said this is this is
a very dangerous moment for the
government
because boris johnson is choosing to
chart his own course
and i think if he is forced off that
course and back to a national circuit
breaker one cabinet
said to me last night you know that
would be absolutely the worst of all
possible worlds worlds for the
government
there would have to be a vote and a
house of comments on it and i think you
would see a massive tory rebellion
and obviously kia stammer you know the
captain hindsight
jive wouldn't work if kia starmer had
called what boris johnson ended up doing
in two or three weeks time and it's very
interesting what you said about northern
ireland i think it raises two crucial
points which is one
how long would this circuit break have
to last for and also
does it work if schools are still open
now we know that kind of primary age
children
don't spread the virus but you know
their parents take them to school they
conjugate at the school gates and the
like
and so i think the way the government
sees us through it is is a situation
quite similar to march
in the worst hit areas in the northwest
and the northeast but with schools open
i think these local
the variation between the different
parts of england is going to become much
more intense in the coming week and the
restrictions are going to become much
tighter in hot spots
and if you look at andy burnham today
you see the political problems that that
is going to pose for the government
there's going to be lots of accusations
that you know the north is being locked
down while life continues as normal and
it's
all close to as normal in the south
let's bring in frozen nelson the editor
of the spectator frame
fraser what's the the mood in downing
street is it um
is it gloomy is it a bit nervous that in
some ways it could be seen to be out in
a limb
against the scientists against labor
sometimes against his own backbenchers
against the north against london i'm not
sure i'd say that i mean right now it
feels that the prime minister is step by
step
ending up in pretty much the national
lockdown situation he said he wanted
to avoid we're in a situation now where
i think the majority
of this country will be breaking the law
if you went to meet a friend for a drink
now you can call that a circuit breaker
you can say it's a series of tier two
restrictions
but it feels pretty much like lockdown
for those
involved and i think that what's
happening is the prime minister has just
lacked the ammunition
to try to argue against the sage
committee they've been very what
somebody in government said to me
recently that the sage has become
politically
self-aware it's been on a crash course
of political dark arts
and it's now quite good at leaking
papers to the press getting the front
page of the next day's paper
bouncing the government into a position
so the prime minister
simply ends up outmaneuvered and bit by
bit
in exactly the position he promised he
wouldn't go
indeed now i'm saying that the
government's surrounded by enemies on
all sides but
um perhaps it's not quite let's go to
ben page from ipsy's mori
because the finance fascinating thing is
that public opinion is still
actually very strongly for restrictions
of the kind that the government has
brought in indeed some of them
suggest that the government should go
for even more restrictions than uh what
boris johnson's
introduced ben i think you've got a
slideshow some numbers talk us through
my public opinion
sure so i don't know how the i don't
know if we're gonna what we're going to
see
first but basically what we can see is
that six out about six out of ten people
have consistently said
since may that we need to take whatever
measures are necessary to control the
virus at whatever cost
okay so here you can see the uh the
trend in the proportion of people just
saying we need to do whatever's
necessary
back in may it was six out of ten fifty
nine percent
in october it's sixty six out of ten
again sixty two percent
there's been a small rise since july who
say that it's all doing more harm than
good but you've got to remember that at
the same time we've
you know we've got by a margin of about
three to one people saying that the
current measures aren't strict enough
uh so so there you are public opinion
isn't really moving um could i have the
next slide please
um and so when you look at the measures
up until the three tier system eight out
of ten people saying
they favor compulsory masks uh three
quarters are
quarantine local lockdown 75 percent
the rule of six 65 and even the young
interestingly say they support the rule
of six and the curfew at ten o'clock
tonight
you know in pubs and bars again there
you are
it's it's it the public are pretty
pretty consistent if we look at more
draconian measures let's go on to what
they might do next
please um you can see again not really
much shift you've got six out of ten
people in october
saying we should just ban all travel in
and out of the country you're going to
have to stay in france forever andrew
you're not going to be allowed back
um and even another complete lockdown
it's people are divided over that so
you've got 40
opposed but you've still got four you
know it's 50 50 roughly 43
in favor i mean it's it's it's quite
astonishing in some ways um but people
are very scared
and i i think it's that unknown quantity
of the risk involved this is the
challenge that
although of course most people know in
their sort of logical brain
that it's very unlikely to kill people
under 30 and most people will catch it
in fact we're finding in our work
testing for it across the country that
the vast majority of people who catch it
don't even have any symptoms in the week
before they test positive
when we test at random in the population
but it's that unknown quantity about
what might happen and the stories of
you know young healthy people catching
it with unforeseen consequences
i think that's part part of this to be
honest
when you break down these figures
by demography by yeah by age
by do you work in the private sector the
public sector are you self-employed
or do you work for a company
are there different differences
variations there there are but not
anywhere near as much as you might
expect and
even you know amongst among the young
you know you've got a quarter opposed to
some of these measures
um you can see in some regions of the
country it's 20
so the regions that are in lockdown
opposition for local lockdowns goes up
to 20
but it's not what i was surprised when i
looked through the numbers before coming
on to talk to you today was that you
just aren't seeing us we aren't seeing
anywhere near as much variation as that
we might see
for example on who are you going to vote
for whereas you as you know there's a
massive age gradient
um on on political support so no it's
across the piece and yes the
self-employed who've had
in many ways have been left short um in
terms of the support from the treasury
are more negative but even there the
balance of opinion is in favor of the
lockdowns james let me come back to
you on this because that would suggest
that those tory back ventures have been
critical of the government for
doing too much on the lockdown side
are actually not representative of
public opinion
yeah i think that is correct i think
that but i think the problem for boris
johnson is
i i i i hope ben will forgive me for
quoting your number i saw from another
pollster
19 of the electorate think that the
current restrictions go too far
the problem is for boris johnson is the
vast majority about 19 percent
are tory voters and this is the issue
for kier starman in calling for a
national circuit break is a fairly
risk-free political option uh partly
because as ben says the public back it
and secondly because the areas where the
rates of cobit are very low
are the south west the east of england
the south east of england
where there are very few labour seats
you know for example in the southwest
the only labor seat is exeter
where there actually is a covid problem
because it's got a university
so the people who would be subject to
extra restrictions if
kierst drama when we went for the
circuit break you know don't vote labor
anyway or don't they aren't labor seats
while as i think it would be much in the
north i think there is a feeling that
you know
this is a policy that is being i'm sure
that it's a policy that has been based
on what is happening in london and the
south
not here you know andy byrne the mayor
of manchester has been
very strongly arguing that you know the
first lockdown was eased too early it
was eased on a london-centric timetable
rather than a timetable that sees to the
north and i think this is the one of the
big challenges for the government is
this virus is so much more regional in
the second wave than it was in this
first wave
but it is much harder to generate a
sense of national solidarity
when uh people in norfolk or devon and
cornwall are living life almost as
normal
while people in uh liverpool and soon to
be manchester
are facing really really strict
restrictions
ben what does the polling tell us about
the mood of
the the famous red wall voters those
were there usually labor voters who
in huge numbers in 29 voted conservative
uh gave mr johnson a seminal part of
giving
him his 80-seat majority what do we know
of their mood now
well there's to be honest the polls both
locally and nationally haven't moved in
any way as much as one might have
expected given how dramatic the
situation
is i mean the parties are neck and neck
pretty much
so kierstama has made up some ground
boris johnson's personal ratings and
indeed the ratings of the government
have now fallen quite markedly
since uh april but actually it's worth
remembering that back in
in the back end of last year the rating
of the government was only 18
satisfied it was one of the lowest
ratings for any government
before the the general election of
december that ipsos more had ever seen
because people were so
fed up with the brexit stalemate uh and
everything else
and so even today even after having
disappointed people and
confusion over lockdowns or not and
diver and delay and all of
all of the rest of it people believing
that we went into lot most people
believe we went into lockdown too late
but even today his satisfaction ratings
are still much better than they were
before the general election so
we need to we need to bear that in mind
you know under ed miliband at one point
labour were 12 points ahead and mr
starman hasn't got anywhere near that
yet
interesting okay ben sing with us uh
we've been talking about the north let's
speak to a northern conservative mp jake
berry
uh he represents rosendale and darwin
that's in lancashire
uh jake of foster tell us what's it like
in your constituency with covert at the
moment
we're uh over 400 per hundred thousand i
represent
two local authorities it's a mixed
picture but both of them are high
but what you have to remember is of
course tier two
which came in yesterday for my
constituents
was a relaxation of the position we have
been in
since august and during that tier two
style lockdown that
we have had across large parts of the
north of england since august
our rates have gone up tenfold so
i think there's a healthy spoonful of
skepticism
that tier two is going to work in
lancashire so are you saying then that
the lockdown rules that you've had so
far
really haven't worked in controlling the
virus
well self-evidently they haven't based
on the number of course we don't know
what would have happened if we hadn't
have had
the tier 2 style lockdown since late
summer but what i would say is this my
impression is and i i disagree
with quite a lot of that polling because
i think it gives people a false choice
people will always choose
health over money i think anyone with a
brain
would choose that but when i go around
lancashire i talk to people and talk to
council leaders across lancashire
the impression i get is very different
is that most people are
simply ignoring everything that's being
said in westminster they
aren't really paying attention to tier
one tier two
tier three they've sort of made up their
own mind
how they're going to deal with this
disease they kind of comply with what
they believe
the rules are but in truth most people
don't know or understand what the rules
are it's not because we are
thick or stupid in languisher it's
because they keep
changing and since august i think across
large parts of the north of england
we're now in our 19th
or 20th different set of rules so we
have a sort of uh
self uh imposed and decided upon
lockdown rules which people are
consistently following to try and keep
themselves safe but
it's not doesn't bear much resemblance
to what the government wants us to do in
my experience
interesting is the government right to
have gone
this local lockdown route to have
different rules depending on the state
of covert in different regions or cities
or so on or if we wanted i saw you
you said to lbc we need simple rules and
a simple message well
right there wrongly you could say that a
national circuit breaker was that
well look the government is right to
have imposed these national restrictions
and of course we're
we're talking about roslindale and
darwin this evening we'll be talking
about reading and dagenham in just a
couple of months time i'm sorry to say
or even a couple of weeks time
so having a national system which people
can understand and as simple
is a country mile better than the
confusing
and uh sort of you know mishmash of
rules that we've had across
the north of england but crucially and
this is where the government has got it
absolutely right this week it needs to
be turned on
and off according to local data and
that's why actually i don't
favor a national lockdown but i would be
pretty relaxed actually
about a local circuit breaker in
lancashire because in truth
we've been in tier 2 since august it
hasn't
worked so we need not to continue what
we know doesn't work
i think we'd be up for trying something
else and our local lockdown across
lancashire
manchester and merseyside based on their
data if that's what they want
i think would be the right thing to do
from where we are today so who should
have the responsibility for deciding to
go into a local
circuit breaker well i think it should
be based on the data i mean if we based
it on data it wouldn't
fall upon them who would take the
decision called council leaders
well i've called on the government to
set up a clear
gateway both in and out of lockdown
and these tiers and also to publish
information
this is sort of we're not telling people
in lancashire whether we're
doing well or badly with what we're
doing you know this test and trace app
it cannot be beyond the width of man to
embed data in the test and trace up
about how we are doing
if you visit any church hall across the
country they will probably have a
thermometer
on the wall telling you how near they're
getting for their church ruth appeal
we like targets people like to know that
what they're doing is working
so i think if you had a clear and fixed
gateway where you came
in and out of tears that the decision
would be made by the data not by
local or national politicians yeah but
data doesn't take decisions data informs
decisions i'm still not quite clear
who would take the decision
or would it be national government well
it would have to be a combination of
both but if you said for example
if your rate is over four hundred
thousand per hundred thousand your
transmission rate
is over x or your hospitalization rate
is over why
it would come to a point you would then
have local and national politicians
saying
we have gone past the trigger point now
is the time for us to implement
tier three lockdown or a a circuit
breaker lockdown whatever it may be
but at least the public would then not
see this bickering between
northern labour mayors and number 10 and
ministers
they would say well actually this is
based on real science
real data that we can understand and we
are part of
therefore we support the decision i just
don't think with the current state of
decision making
that i think we've lost the public
frankly in many parts of the north of
england
has has the government then therefore
not handled the north well
well i think it certainly could have
handled the north better
i think our messaging has been poor i
think we've
as i said i think we've lost large parts
of the public's attention in the north
of england it feels to me funnily enough
a bit like
brexit felt just as we were coming up
towards the general election that we
were bickering about things
in parliament and most people i spoke
about well we won't we voted for it we
don't care how you do it
just get on with it when i talk to
people across the north of england they
say look
you know we don't want you bickering in
parliament about what's going on and
whether we should listen to our mayor
or council leader or government we just
want you
to get on with tackling this disease and
that may be a completely unreasonable
ask of the public that
it's very very difficult but it sort of
feels to me
that that's where their opinion is and
that's a very dangerous moment
for parliament and it's very dangerous
moment for these
northern mayors i think as well
could be dangerous for your party too i
mean the conservative party is now to
some extent the party of the north
since the december 2019 election you're
no longer
just the party of the leafy home
counties are you in danger with the way
the government's gone about this
of uh losing the north well i think it's
far too early to
talk about losing the north but you know
there are 80
northern mps that we are literally the
prime minister's majority so he needs to
look after us bluntly but i also think
labour's in quite a lot of trouble with
this as well
because what we are now seeing is a big
division opening
between the labour mayors of the north
of england who are pushing the
government
saying every single decision should be
based on local data
and on what local politicians think and
of course kirsten who's calling for
a national lockdown that's all very well
it may be the right thing to do in parts
of north of england
to have a circuit breaker but what i
don't want to see
is when rates go up in cornwall or in
the south of england
for the north to be pushed into another
national circuit breaker
just as other numbers have gone down and
our economy is
starting to recover so yes i'm there is
divisions within the conservative party
but i think that
moved by kierstarma this week was a
bigger mistake than we yet realized
because it's creating big division both
with him and his mps
in the north of england who many of his
mps are campaigning to have a local
approach
and of course many of these mayors who
are absolutely appearing on our tv
channels every night saying
it has to be a locally led approach
that's not what kir's
suggesting and i think it's starting to
cause him some trouble and yet andy
burnham the mayor of manchester and
others seem to imply i seem to say i
take the position that they
they would rather have a national
circuit breaker as mr stomach calls it
than being placed into a tier by
central government are they right
well i don't think they are i don't
think a national circuit breaker is the
right way to go i support
many of the arguments andy burnham's
made actually i've supported him in the
commons
about we have to have local data guiding
these decisions
why should uh cornwall be put in
lockdown
now okay that's bad for cornwall now but
my real concern as i've said
is in two three months time i don't want
my constituency put back into lockdown
because they've got covered in the south
so let me just get you to sum up jake
berry
what should take your in the surrounding
areas or
areas in the north that have a similar
number of covet cases
what should the proper way ahead be
as we sit here tonight for your area
okay so the three-tiered system has been
in now just for 24 hours
the incubation period for this disease
is 14 days so we can't simply can't say
whether this tier 2 tier 3 is going to
work yet so i think we have to give it
at least
two weeks although i said there is a
large spoon of skepticism across the
north of england
because we look at many of these
restrictions say well we've had them for
over two months
and they haven't worked but i want to
give the scientists and the computer
models
the benefit of the doubt so let's give
them a fortnight
if things haven't moved by then if we
are still seeing a
rapid increase in growth rate of this
disease and transmissibility within the
community
i don't think there is any other choice
for the government
except to move to some form of circuit
breaker
based on local data and i think it
should be done on a county-by-county
basis so
you would choose to do lancashire you
may then choose to greater manchester
merseyside maybe areas of west yorkshire
and we go in and out of that circuit
breaker
based on local data so liverpool may be
in it for a fortnight
lancashire maybe in it for three weeks
greater manchester in it for a month
so be it but each one of those local
circuit breakers
has to be backed by proper gover
government financial support
and that's really what we're looking to
the chancellor now to come forward if we
do go into that situation
to say how the government's going to
support people and businesses throughout
what will be a
difficult and cold and miserable period
in the winter
you don't think the government's done
enough do you on that front
well i think that we should be doing
more i've
i've been quite clear that i think we
should keep the 80 wage subsidy for
those who are
low paid uh you can do that by
guaranteeing 80
of the wages up to a different level
it's currently
66.6 up to two thousand one hundred
we of course could say well you know the
first thousand or the first twelve
hundred quid
will guarantee eighty percent but we're
coming towards christmas
and people who often work in the
hospitality
industry on low wages you know we'll be
feeling the pinch already
hospitality haven't been shut down for
much of the year and i don't think it's
unreasonable for them to say to the
government
actually we expect you to keep
supporting our wages
at 80 percent jake perry thanks for that
stay with us there'll be some questions
i'm sure
viewers at home you can send your
questions to spectator tv at spectator
dot co dot uk
let's move on to france and islamic
extremism
president macron's in trey isn't just
filled with pandemic
response so it certainly has a lot of
that there are curfews proper curfews
not the pubs closing at 10
but actually off the streets don't be
out after 10 o'clock in nine major
french cities
uh this week uh but even so in a recent
speech the president found time
to draw up new battle lines in the fight
against
islamic extremism in france ayan hussey
ali is a feminist activist former dutch
politician
and she's written in this week's
spectator commending president macron's
speech
that says he should go further she uh
joins me
now uh i am thank you for being with us
what is it that you liked about what
president macron had said
well i i i loved it that he defined the
problem as clearly as possible because i
think
uh the failure of many western
leaders at least as far back as 9 11
2001
was there euphemizing
and obfuscating the problem and calling
it anything but its real name
so i think it takes a great deal of
courage for a leader
on that level to come out and say what
we are
facing is islamist separatism
and so i think that's a fast step
but then what follows out of that you
know i'm a little skeptical because i've
had
uh angela merkel declare that
multiculturalism was dead
uh i've at one point even had david
cameron say he was going to take on
uh these groups and um here in the
united states of america i've had
president trump
say he was going to go after the
ideological not just
jihad the the violent islamists
but those who dedicate their time to
poisoning and spreading um these
ideas and we'll see
well we'll see what what he does with it
but what is meant by this word
separatism
can you just explain that i mean to my
knowledge
french muslims are not calling for a
separate
french muslim state
so the thing is if you understand
political islam as a separate philosophy
and it is a philosophy that is
confronting liberal societies and saying
the liberal philosophies that western
societies are based on are corrupt
they're wrong they have to be replaced
with something else
what then these islamists have done is
they have taken advantage
of the immigrant populations and
convinced them uh in the case of france
for instance
that they are in a nation-state within a
nation-state
and so it's it's it's very clear and i
think it's it's the right thing for him
to do
to confront these islamists
but what's the evidence that the
vast majority or even a substantial
minority of french muslim
are islamists
well there's a great deal of evidence
for that that's been building up and
it's not just in france it's in the uk
it's in other european countries and
it's here in america
um the fact that there are islamists
there's been plenty of evidence for that
you've had here in
in you've had about as a majority are
even substantially not there are of
course you're quite right there are
islamists
in uh in france but what's the evidence
that
they represent even a substantial
minority of the french muslim community
substantial enough to plot terrorist
attacks
substantial enough to refuse to learn
the french language and live by french
norms and french standards and there's
a substantial evidence to show us that
there is
what i would say the white french would
regard as an
underclass of people who just refuse to
be or are
incapable of being assimilated into the
wider
french economy and society
and what you know
the question then is why is that
happening
and i think that um not just
the french i in this we're using france
as an example but i think that
immigration out of muslim countries
into western society has yes
brought a somewhat uh culture clash
but leaders have failed constantly and
they failed in four ways they
failed to make it very clear what
islamism is
they've allied with the wrong people
they have failed
to to
regulate immigration and there's been an
if
you know a failure by leadership to use
the um foreign tools or foreign policy
tools
uh to stop foreign countries from
basically usurping the
minorities and and look at a country
like turkey
and what it's doing in france what it's
doing in in germany
um there's been a failure to use
foreign policy tools to stop
these countries from financing
islamist ideology on european soil
i know and we have to let you go shortly
just two other
quick questions i mean there is
undoubtedly there is an islamic
underclass in france
you see that in some of the suburbs of
the bigger cities they feel excluded
they are almost separate in some ways
but almost every western country has an
underclass like that
and it's not not always islamic in in
britain
you could see a white underclass uh has
developed
in cities the city of glasgow your
husband city
uh for example in many other parts of
the west you see a black underclass
developed over many years feeling
excluded
i mean given that most french immigrants
are
muslim that's what makes french
immigration different from british
or american or even german immigration
they're mainly muslim
was it not an evil inevitable it may
have nothing to do with islam
that there is an islamic underclass in
france
yes indeed and i think one so
one of the failures i mentioned is this
failure to regulate immigration
give the muslim communities that are
already in france an opportunity
to go through the process of integration
or assimilation as we call it here in
the united states
and use the tools that
a state has to make it very clear
to those individuals and organizations
that are turning
people's minds away from what it is to
be
french and to to assimilate
and instead brainwashing them into
radical islam
those organizations and those
individuals are groups that they
shouldn't have partnered with and for a
long time they did
and for a long time france and it's not
just
france but france has pretty much
outsourced what they thought was the
integration process
to other countries and i think they have
to stop that that is my piece in the
industry i think there is an awakening
now
and i hope that micron really means it
and um
that he isn't just saying these things
to win
the election in 2022 um but that he is
dedicated to really doing
something about this problem and setting
an example for the other european
leaders well we shall see how he follows
it up after this speech uh ayan hersey
ali thank you
for writing your piece of all the
spectator uh this weekend for joining us
from the hoover institution
in california thank you very much now
just to cheer you up let's
talk brexit the brexit negotiations
rumble on
uh those doing the talking uh blow hot
and cold at the prospect of a deal
the prime minister insisted there had to
be one by mid-october well by my
calendar here on my computer it's
october the 15th
there's still no deal but nobody's
walking away yet eu leaders as we speak
are meeting for a summit in brussels
they seem to like them they've got one
this week uh james let me go straight to
you
where are we what's happening what's
going on so andrew it's been a rather
dramatic day today
uh we had european council meetings you
say
then ursula on the line the commission
president had to leave it because a
member of our outer office has tested
positive for coronavirus so she had to
get out of the building quickly and go
into
isolation we then had a rather punchy
set
of uh conclusions on brexit issued by
the european union
essentially saying uh if there's going
to be a deal
it's up to the uk to move and uh
essentially
balls in your court then we have from
david frost the uk's
chief negotiator a fairly robust
response to that saying it's a pretty
bizarre ass approach to a negotiation to
say that all the movement has to come
from one side or the other
michelle barnier has now come up to say
that you know yes they do want to
accelerate the talks they do want to
intensify them and speed them up
and i think in an attempt to say look
the council conclusions of the council's
conclusions but don't think we don't
want to carry on talking
so i i think it is what we are
essentially in right now is a game of
chicken between the two sides
uh the but neither side wants to
back down and you know we are this is
our old friends
fish and the level playing field the the
really big issue but i thought there was
an interesting moment when emmanuel
macron arrived at the council he made
his kind of usual doorstep remarks
and he said that he wouldn't accept
french fishermen not continue to have
access to uk waters now that is
interesting
because i don't think anyone's talking
about french fishermen not having
access to uk waters they're talking
about them not having the same level of
access the same quota
as they have at the moment and i think
that does indicate a
certain possible flexibility from macro
but you know i i still think it is more
likely than not but there'll be a deal
but i mean there are a few twists in
this tale to come
and fraser you've been following these
you you think a deal will still be done
and
and it's like it may it may end up this
way it's kind of
inconceivable though is it not that
whether or not there's a deal should be
determined by fish
i mean people will just think really
that's
the real issue you couldn't agree on
that and it may be different because the
french position i would suggest fraser
is kind of
it is indefensible they the french
position at the moment is to say well it
doesn't matter
you're leaving we get the same access to
these waters as we've always had
um that
that's a political position it's not a
defensible position is it
no it'd be rather embarrassing for the
government if it were to cede
this point the funny thing is that boris
and macron are very close perhaps
um one of the closest relationships in
europe right now they text each other
the whole time
and macron has um you know he's made
his several times he said to the to his
basement north there's no way i'm going
to sell you out
and similarly michael gove himself the
son of a fishmonger said to the
fishermen don't worry we're not going to
sell you out
so one of these two will um will have to
budge
and it wouldn't surprise me actually if
it is britain
that budges there was something about
the drama of a few weeks ago with the
internal market bill where they said
they were going to
tear up international law and i thought
to myself i wonder if they're doing that
in preparation for the concession
further down the road to basically sound
really brave and hardline to make it
easier to offer the french
that concession on fish and my guts i'm
feeling is that we will end up with a
deal
we'll get pretty much free trade and but
it won't be a final deal it will be one
for revision
so if we for example were to do give
state aid to our companies and the eu
might
change its regime if we were to do a big
free trade deal with a
country the eu regarded as a competitor
it might change its regime
so this might be a process rather than
an event
and the process isn't it's um well but
you know i would say this is the end of
it
i've got horrible feeling this is about
to be the beginning of something
james if there is to be a deal some kind
of deal may not be a very deep deal
and as frieza says it's a deal that will
uh lend itself to being reopened
depending on future actions down the
road
what's the timetable now we're on
october the 15th
so what when would we see a deal if
there's going to be one
so i think you would need to have clear
progress by the end of the month
because that is when the eu's deadline
for d
for removing the uh contentious clauses
in the internal market bill that seeks
to override
the withdrawal agreement and then i
think you might have an agreement in the
middle of november
and then a rush to ratify it in both in
the european parliament
and i think there's an interesting
aspect here which is i think both
negotiating teams
don't want to deal too early because
they have a fear but if the deal comes
early
you will have eu member states seeking
to unpick it
people saying you know one of the
coastal eight might say for example
we like this deal but we'd like a little
bit more on fish or oh yeah
and i think this is the issue that you
know they i think one from the moment
that barney and frost i would say shake
hands but obviously won't be allowed to
shake hands in the current
situation when they barney and frost
initial the deal
to ratification they don't want any
changes from that process on so
i think both sides wouldn't mind a
fairly rapid
uh ratification with no time to ask too
many questions now one of the issues
there is
when the european parliament gets
railroaded it it gets very sensitive
uh and uh wants to assert itself so that
that could be problematic
but ultimately i think if they're you
know i think that
all these deadlines keep moving to the
right when it comes to brexit they
always
do but i think you know progress by the
end of this month
deal uh then two weeks say to turn that
into legal tech so deal on the 15th of
november say
okay we shall see i'll go to the
american elections out of the way first
as well it's a busy time and whether
it's going to be local lockdowns or
a national circuit breaker or whatever
let's go straight to questions first
one's from alan simmons
uh he says is it not time for everyone
to take some of the financial burden as
a pensioner
i think the triple lock should be
abandoned he's referring to this triple
lock
which guarantees whether it's inflation
or wages
that there is always a decent rise in
state pensions
every year katie is that on the horizon
there's a way of
raising some money or saving the
government some money or
does the prime minister feel look most
of my votes come from the over 60s
it was a promise in the manifesto we
can't touch that i mean i think if the
chancellor was number 10 not number 11
the triple lock could be on the way out
but
boris johnson is committed to it and i
think it's
a the target voter um it's been
interesting i mean students have not
been treated
particularly well during this period and
18 to 24 year olds has never really been
the key
tory targo vote um so pensioners i think
are seen as one that has to have to be
kept on side but also i think there's
something else which is
boris johnson has a trust problem his
whole team are very aware of this
uh they're worried in their election
campaign
and their untrustworthiness would be an
issue for him
so i think to go back on a manifesto
commitment to go back on things like
that is seen as something which
come back to haunt him in many ways
which is why i think the triple lock
does look as though it
is going to stick around and despite the
fact there are several uh
high-profile figures in this government
who have serious uh
reservations about it when you're
looking at the burden going forward
right i suspect it will survive simply
for political reasons you don't stuff
your own voters is
usually a way to proceed whether that's
right or wrong it's another
matter keith fair has a question why
doesn't mr johnson take the opportunity
to put local politicians on the hook
let them decide between jobs and health
um what's wrong with that uh argument
fraser
um well local politicians in this
country have got very few powers it's
funny
the metro mayors are almost almost
entirely tokenistic
now there is a case that yes you should
give them finance powers tax raising
powers
and let them decide both sides of the
equation rather than simply
and say yes let's get restrictions on
and please give us
um lots of welfare but the architecture
of the british government remains a very
centralized
architecture so even though lots of
people have been created
in the regions to speak up for their
locality
they don't really have the power that's
quite deliberate
and i don't think the treasury or number
10 is going to let go of that power
anytime soon you agree with that jake
berry
well i actually think it's what the
government has attempted to do over the
last
four or five days or so but these local
politicians
they know that they get they don't want
to make the decision in many cases they
don't want to carry the can for this
they would say why should they and they
know that when the government
contacts them as they have been doing so
you must make this decision
they can afford not to make the decision
let time tick by
and then of course the government has to
come in and make it
after all and i think that is the uh how
they are responding
to number 10 trying to hang them on the
hook
are is our politics changing though
to more localism i mean it's
it's always been in modern times it's
always been the case i was speaking of
england here just
just of england that uh in the end
central government had to build the
responsibility so unlike america
where the central government was
prepared to let new york go bust in the
1970s
because they knew in the end it was the
new york politicians that would take the
rap
for it even the thatcher government was
not prepared to let liverpool go bust
because he knew that just the way we
look at things
in the end no matter how bad the
liverpool government had been this
central government
would get the blame for one of our great
cities going bust
is that still basically the culture of
our politics
i think it is but i think it's certainly
changing i mean most people couldn't
name their local authority
leader uh but they can i would guess
most the people who live in greater
manchester
or liverpool or in south yorkshire or
the tease valley name
their metro mayors and of course let's
not forget that the stated policy of
this government
in fact set out by the prime minister in
his first domestic policy speech when he
entered number 10 is to have full
mayoral
devolution across the entirety of the
north of england when you get to that
point
i think the relationship does change and
if we
move a rogue i would love to see us go
down which fraser mentioned about sort
of
more fiscal devolution to these metro
mayors so they can balance the scale
i mean everyone likes father christmas
but occasionally he delivers a credit
card bill in january
we need them to have responsibility for
raising the money as well as spending it
and i think
slowly because these powers have to be
ripped
from the arms of civil servants and
ministers in whitehall
but i think slowly that is their action
of travel in our country
ron knox has a question for you jake
berry can you explain
why you chose newark for extra funding
in last year's towns fund
for deprived areas it just happened to
be in robin
robert generic's constituency he of
course being the cabinet minister for
local government
well uh newark is a former mining town
so
may uh people who live there i'm sure
think it's fantastic but
the townsfund is spent on uh a variety
of towns some of which are very deprived
some of which are
in the mid tier but none of them i can
tell you are wealthy
and i would ask your viewers to have a
look at the nao report on this
very government policy which had a deep
look under the bonnet
said nothing to see move on and i think
it's probably time we did
but didn't didn't you okay funding
for his consistency and then he okayed
funding
for your constituency sounds a little
bit
too close for comfort well i mean you
may say that it's following the
ministerial code
you may disagree with the ministerial
code but it does seem right to me that
that's the way it happens
all right anthony storm has kierstarma's
entry
into the fray backfired on the labour
party i think anthony is probably
too soon to say but let me come to ben
here ben
if the labor party was uh
to show success in rebuilding itself
what would you expect the polls to show
in
2021 i mean even putting covered aside
would you not normally expect the
opposition
party to begin two years into government
that by by next year to begin to show
some kind of
decent lead in the polls absolutely
and so far they haven't achieved that
and the labour party remains
very unpopular um you know so kierstama
is
is now much more popular than his party
with the electorate but
it's this seems to be i mean his front
bench are i think most voters would have
great difficulty in naming any of them
and of course the party itself is still
still seems quite damaged so
he's doing quite well on some personal
characteristics against boris johnson
but it isn't
it isn't translated into success if he's
vindicated over some of this if the
if this turns out to be a sort of
massive moment where finally the
the sort of the accusations of
incompetence
stick on the government and you know on
some
some of these things star is doing
better than johnson but
if at that and there's a huge death rate
the economy massive recession
and finally stammer starts to unveil
some policies that seem attractive
then you might see it change but so far
i'm in a way i've been surprised that
labour haven't managed to go into the
lead
uh given the perils the government's
faced and the difficulties they've got
i agree i'm i'm a little bit surprised
too though i suppose
some mr starbucks people in the labor
party would say you have no idea the
ruin jeremy corbyn did to the labour
party
and we can't build pretty impressive we
can't
rebuild that overnight we're in for a
long haul as mr kenneth found out of
course
yeah taking over from uh michael food in
83.
uh aleister dick has a question james i
put it to you
does the panel see a return to the
fishing wars i mean
for those of us who wrote about the cod
war with iceland which i think
memory certainly right we actually lost
in the end i mean
that would just be too good to be true
james would it not to get a great
fish war going i i think they're most
likely kind of fishing exchange
according to the government's own kind
of contingency planning documents
is between english and french fishermen
just off the coast but because of a
channel islands
uk territorial waters push up really
quite close
to french water so there are fishing
communities in northern france that have
uh for generations fish those waters in
the event of no deal
they would not be allowed to fish there
anymore and as we've seen with french
fishermen in some previous exchange in
the channel
that they are not shy about you know
throwing anchors at other boats and all
those kind of things
so things could get quite fruity there
and again it's one of the reasons why i
slightly suspect there's going to be a
deal
there are so many problems in both the
uk and france in dealing with covid
can you really add a scallop wall um to
that list of issues
yeah indeed i now know why the
government built these two aircraft
carriers though
[Laughter]
that's how i don't think they'll be
deployed on the channel um
patricia matthews has a question for you
fraser is boris johnson
too soft in the cultural war should he
be learning
from mackerel i mean maybe at the moment
he just hasn't got time fraser
um well i'm afraid to say i think the
culture wars it's a strange phrase but
it is one of the most important things
for a lot of young people this is
politics he's hopeless on this he's
terrified
of it he runs away the black lives
matter protest where they were saying
that
britain's a racist country he couldn't
even give a defense there
a macron's speech he gave him friday was
absolute masterclass he wasn't just
um being quite tough on islamic
hardliners he was praising what he
called the
the enlightenment islam and he was
drawing a clear distinction between the
vast majority who are integrated french
citizens
and the and the jihadists who are trying
to put people in separate ghettos
and we've actually translated it into
english and put into the spectator
website that's how much we liked
a macron's speech but boris johnson
would rather
run a million miles just enter a
discussion on any of this
and i think that's a great shame because
it's a hugely
powerful potent force in politics right
now and i think the argument's all there
for the tories to make
well it was very different when he was
doing your job fraser
there we go he's sitting in a different
seat now
we're gonna leave it there now it's just
gone seven o'clock we thank you all for
joining the week in 60 minutes we'd love
to find out
what you thought of it how we could
improve on it you can see our camera
work
is already getting better in london not
in mine yet we're saving up to get me a
better camera too
uh you can send any thoughts to
spectator tv
spectator dot co dot uk that's spectator
tv at spectator
dot co dot uk if you liked it you can
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
a surefire way
not to miss any future warnings because
you click the button
on the bottom right of your screen and
you get a warning when the next edition
is coming up
and before we go of course we'd like to
thank all of our guests
who are being with us from outside the
spectator jake berry
ben page and ali who had to go
there katie bowles fraser nelson and uh
james forsythe
for the home team thanks to all of our
guests
as i said and a very special thanks to
our sponsor charles stanley
it's one of the uk's leading wealth
management firms
and one of the oldest companies on the
london
stock exchange so it should know how to
look after your money
we hope you'll join us again next
thursday at 6 p.m london time for
another
the week in 60 minutes until now then
bye
you